all right y'all we're back and i'm here
with the lovely amy adams give it up
[Applause]
um in honor of her awesome and creepy
netflix movie the woman in the window
it's time to play
what's creeping up on
up on me
[Music]
get it jesse so amy and i each have
screens behind us
but we can't see what's in our own
screens so we'll give each other clues
about what's creeping up
without saying the name of what it is um
if we can correctly guess
ten things in two rounds together this
is a team
effort amy okay the audience will win a
cool prize i think we got this you ready
okay yeah i got it give me okay all
right all right
okay so you're gonna give me clues first
ready
and go yes okay it runs on a track
uh an athlete says choo choo
oh oh a train yes
oh this is terrif terrifying pennywise
as one of these
that they're in the circus they're in
the circus
yes oh she's our favorite person she
taught me to knit um
oh goodness okay so e.t came out of one
of these they're sightings they're up in
the sky
spaceship oh okay this lays
eggs chicken some people are yeah
um oh jurassic park this is the villain
it's scary oh uh
uh the the the the the
you're on what on you're on uh things on
you're being pulled by a boat the
go-go's do this in one of their videos
what tube tubing what
time was up what was it water skiing
sorry water oh god
i don't want our ski all i could think
of is the go-go's and i was like
i'm like the good news that was
awesome we already got six we only need
you to get four
amy you're amazing so i'm giving clues
now let's do this we get four ready
and go oh um the walking dead
zombies yeah wait what oh oh egypt
they they would there was a problem
sorry sorry i thought it was a zombie
that's okay
oh jaws a shark okay
um talladega knights he was in it
so yep
um oh wait we already said this one
walking dead
mommy no no before the one before oh
dummy
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh i can't believe mommy ended
up being one i thought it was
i mean zombie i thought it was a zombie
whatever um
okay so we got 10 correct which means
we're amazing
let's lead with that and everybody's a
winner today so this is for everyone in
the house seats
monarch rain swimwear is meticulously
crafted in new york city
with high quality fabrics and
sustainable materials their swimmer is
as unique and beautiful as the women
wearing them
i have a couple i love them just in time
for summer you're all getting a 300
monarch rain gift card
they're really cute swimsuits no joke i
own two um thank you for dropping by amy
i love you even more now
thank you so much it's so nice to get to
spend this time with you
absolutely i can't wait for one day
you're here in person because i really
do want to sing with you okay
oh i thought i was like oh you can't
wait to come over to my back room and do
some karaoke but you're also invited
hey i will do that that's a nice
appetizer for what's to come i will
totally come over absolutely
or we might find your husband in there
just jamming by himself which is the
best part um
he's like programmed about 50 songs so
you can come back in two hours
all right well everybody amy's new movie
the woman in the window is now on
netflix y'all have to watch it it's so
trippy it's so good
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help